Shure:  嗯楼上几瓶酒也是我放的
Shure: Hmm, the upstairs part is so Chinese.
Jake: 就是咱就不要做意大利面了
Jake: Let's not make pasta.
Jake: 哈哈哈有没有这个
Jake: Hahaha, do we have this?
Lucia: 没事火锅我也会
Tasha: Will I be part of this activity?
Tasha: 有没有这个活动吗
Tasha: Do we have this activity?
Jake: 有有做饭的活动
Jake: Yes, we have a cooking activity.
Jake: 没有做意大利面的活动
Jake: No pasta-making activity though.
Alice: 你们喜欢酸汤麻辣菜吗
Jake: Do you like spicy and sour dishes?
Alice: 很喜欢喝那个
Alice: I really like that.
Jake: 那可以做一个
Jake: We can make a fresh one.
Alice: 很鲜的
Tasha: 你做给我吃吧
Jake: If you want to eat brain dish, you eat it.
Alice: 啊
Alice: 你吃菇类吗
Alice: Do you eat mushrooms?
Alice: 菌类
Alice: Mushrooms are fine.
Alice: 松花蛋你吃吗
Alice: Do you eat century eggs?
Tasha: 没吃过啊
Lucia: 就是皮蛋
Alice: It's the preserved egg.
Alice: 黑的那个
Alice: The black one.
Tasha: 也没吃过
Alice: Haven't tried it either?
Jake: 那好啊
Jake: Well, it looks really ugly.
Alice:炒
Alice:确实
Tasha: Indeed, I don't want to eat it.
Jake: 还是试一试吧
Jake: But you should give it a try.
Lucia: 长得丑
Jake: It looks ugly, that's one thing.
Lucia: 我以为皮蛋是一个地域性菜系
Lucia: I thought preserved eggs were a regional dish.
Lucia: 就可能你们那边啊
Lucia: Maybe from your area?
Tasha: 没有有凉菜啊
Lucia: No cold dishes, huh?
Lucia: 不过那个我也吃的很好
Lucia: But I eat it well.
Alice: 只是你没有主动吃它
Lucia: You just don't eat it voluntarily.
Lucia: 啊对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Alice: 不知道够不够
Alice: Not sure if it's enough.
Alice: 买几个吧
Alice: Let's buy a few.
Alice: 待会写上  我写吧
Alice: Let me write it down.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 你猜
Tasha: Guess.
Jake: 打面糊差不多吧
Jake: Beating batter, I suppose.
Shure:  打鸡蛋的那个
Tasha: It can beat eggs too.
Tasha: 啊对
Shure: Yeah, right.
Jake: 鸡蛋是吧
Jake: Eggs, huh?
Jake: 就那个鸡蛋
Jake: Just eggs.
Jake: 鸡蛋我看怎么会多一些
Jake: I see more eggs.
Jake: 说忘了吧
Jake: Forgot, right?
Jake: 一口
Jake: One bite.
Shure:  但是看了是
Jake: But look, is this a Thai machine?
Alice:不是一个烫
Alice:上烫娃娃菜你吃吗
Tasha: And you mount it like this.
Katrina: 我都吃
Katrina: 你做菜吗
Alice:啊不这就是不是菜
Shure: Then press it, it's not a dish.
Alice: 就是一个汤嘛
Alice: It's just a soup.
Alice: 算是不算很主食哎
Shure: It's not really a main course.
Lucia: 咱们这里要买美分纸吗
Lucia: We're buying food here.
Jake: 你的描述
Jake: Your description...
Jake: 然后最后会兑现成一个现成
Jake: And then it will finally turn into a ready-made masking tape.
Katrina: 美纹纸
Shure:  对让AI更了解我们人类
Shure: Right, to help AI understand humans better.
Katrina: 就是贴墙上的，我姐跟我说是无痕的
Tasha: 我知道啊
Tasha: I know, right?
Tasha: 对哦画画的时候会用到
Tasha: Yeah, you use it when you're painting.
Lucia: 哦我以为是那
Lucia: Oh, I thought it was...
Lucia: 那种就是用来
Tasha: 美缝
Lucia:对对对
Tasha: 也可以再多买点别的水果
Tasha: You can also buy more fruits.
Tasha: 装饰在巧蛋糕上
Tasha: To decorate the cake.
Lucia: 所以这个是那种
Lucia: So this is the kind...
Lucia: 就是画布旁边贴的那个
Lucia: You stick it on the side of the canvas, right?
Lucia: 对对对就
Lucia: Right, right, just...
Tasha: 是画纸上面贴的胶
Tasha: It's the tape you stick on the drawing paper.
Lucia: 而且我都不知道他叫什么
Lucia: And I don't even know what it's called.
Alice:调料在哪算了
Alice:再来一个吧
Tasha: 美文纸啊
Tasha: It's masking tape.
Lucia: 原来如此一直把它当成是一种胶带
Shure: So that's what it is, I always thought it was a kind of tape.
Lucia: 类似的东西
Lucia: Something similar.
Tasha: 就是纸胶布嘛
Tasha: It's paper tape.
Tasha: 对对对嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, right.
Lucia: 然后就反正我看到是那个东西
Lucia: And whenever I see it, I know it's that thing.
Alice:胡椒
Lucia: 我就知道是他了
Lucia: I just know it's that.
Alice:粉
Lucia: 但我不知道他叫什么
Lucia: But I don't know its name.
Alice: 味精
Alice: MSG.
Alice: 盐是不是有了你就不写了
Alice: If you have salt, you don't need to write it down, right?
Lucia: 我看看这边这个箱子要不要收拾一下
Lucia: Let me see if this box needs to be tidied up.
Alice: ok了
Alice: 你手好好看
Alice: Your hands are so small.
Alice: 你是精灵系的吗
Alice: Are you from the fairy race?
Katrina: 这是我雍和宫求的这是我抖音直播看的
Alice: 感觉喜欢喜欢那种森系的感觉吗
Alice: Do you like that forest-style feeling?
Katrina: 嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: 雍和宫
Lucia: Yeah, fish hotpot.
Alice: 雍和宫还蛮准的
Alice: Fish hotpot is quite accurate.
Katrina: 真的准我求了两个
Katrina: 我帮我两个好朋友求考研上岸
Katrina: 都考上了
Katrina: 其他两个没考上
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 然后我求财感觉财运还不错的
Tasha: 这两个规格不一样吗我感觉
Tasha: Aren't these two specs different? I feel like they are.
Katrina: 买点草莓买点小金橘
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 嗯不了不了不了算了
Tasha: Hmm, no, no, never mind.
Katrina: 但是雍和宫是不是求姻缘求不了
Alice: 没在那求过姻缘从不求
Alice: I've never prayed for love there, never.
Lucia: 这个是哪位宝宝的
Lucia: Whose baby is this?
Alice:或者白玉菇
Lucia: 好像也是某个电器的配件
Lucia: Seems like it's an accessory for an appliance.
Tasha: 嗯这是送的
Jake: Hmm, this is a gift.
Tasha: 没有这个好用
Tasha: Not as good as this one.
Lucia: 啊那这个不是
Lucia: Oh, so this isn't it.
Lucia: 反正不太需要是吧
Lucia: We don't really need it, right?
Lucia: 啊OK OK
Lucia: Oh, OK, OK.
Lucia: 我把外面那个箱子稍微收拾一下
Lucia: I'll tidy up the box outside.
Lucia: 那些不需要的我就扔掉了
Lucia: I'll throw away the unnecessary stuff.
Lucia: 这个配件先撂这吧
Lucia: Let's leave this accessory here for now.
Lucia: 说不定能用上
Jake: Maybe we should put this item out.
Lucia: 然后说明书
Lucia: Are all the manuals complete?
Alice:洗了吗
Jake:这不能冲水吗
Lucia: 这个哎算了
Lucia: Never mind.
Tasha: 应该没装电池吧
Tasha: There should be a battery, right?
Katrina:  放在外面
Katrina: It's outside.
Alice: 电池是不是在一个小袋子里
Tasha: 在一个袋子里哎
Tasha: In a bag, right?
Tasha: 那个袋子
Tasha: That bag.
Tasha: 嗯被扔掉了吗
Tasha: Hmm, was it thrown away?
Alice: 我记得刚才见到他了
Alice: I remember seeing it just now.
Tasha: 嗯哦
Alice:电子是吧
Tasha: 对电子
Jake: Yeah, there's no more foam.
Alice: 是一个泡沫那个那个有泡泡的那个
Jake: Maybe we should check the bag with bubbles.
Alice: 所以那个袋子去哪了
Alice: So, where did that bag go?
Alice: 他长得很像垃圾
Jake: He looks like trash.
Alice: 会不会被误扔掉了
Jake: The turtle got thrown away, right?
Alice: 这先搁这
Alice: 这搁那边
Tasha: 他测的不准呀
Tasha: It's not accurate.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha, this box isn't good, don't scan it.
Jake: 啊多少度
Jake: Ah, what's the temperature? 27 degrees.
Tasha: 27度
Jake:那不要死了
Tasha: 哈哈哈哦哦
Tasha: Hahaha, oh oh.
Tasha: 在上升
Alice: 他得有一个传递的过程
Alice: There needs to be a passing process.
Jake: 我的体感温度是吧
Jake: Oh, this one is okay.
Lucia: 30多
Lucia: More than 30, keep this one.
Tasha: 好那他就是真的了
Tasha: Okay, then it's real.
Jake:有用是吧我多少度30多
Tasha: Haha, take those.
Alice:30多点
Tasha: 他里面原本有一颗垫子
Tasha: There used to be a cushion inside.
Tasha: 嗯那就够了
Tasha: Yeah, that's enough.
Alice:好那用不着它了
Tasha: It's hard work growing up, maybe.
Lucia: 有剪刀或者之类的东西吗
Lucia: Do we have scissors or something like that? Scissors?
Alice:有剪刀
Tasha: 剪刀在
Tasha: 这瓶水是我的吗
Tasha: Is this bottle of water mine?
Lucia: 呃应该是你的
Jake: Uh, it should be yours.
Lucia: 这瓶水是我的
Lucia: This bottle of water is mine.
Tasha: 行可以拿笔在上面简单写一下
Tasha: Okay, you can just write on it with a pen.
Alice:剪刀不知道在哪
Lucia: 虽然有可能会被蹭掉
Lucia: Although it might rub off.
Shure:  可以拿白色写
Shure: Just write on it simply.
Lucia: OPS sorry
Lucia: Oops, sorry.
Alice: 你喝吗
Jake: Hmm, drink it?
Alice:给你倒
Lucia: Is this a bento?
Tasha: 我喝这个
Tasha: I'll drink this.
Tasha: 你不是不喝饮料吗
Tasha: Don't you not drink beverages?
Alice: 这是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Tasha: 哦呵呵呵
Tasha: Oh, haha.
Jake: 嗯这是喝饮料啊嗯
Tasha: Hmm, this is my drink, yeah.
Tasha: 杨老师洗到累吗
Tasha: Jake, are you tired?
Jake:不会累
Shure:  杨老师是Supersaya啊
Shure: Jake is a Super Saiyan.
Shure:  杨老师是超级赛亚人
Tasha: 赛亚人是什么意思
Tasha: What's a Saiyan?
Alice: 一种神奇的物种
Alice: It's something magical. 5:20 sleep.
Shure:  5:20睡觉 13:14准时醒
Shure: Sleep at 5:20, wake up at 13:14 sharp.
Shure:  你这个9点准时有点反人类
Shure: Your 9 o'clock sharp is a bit inhumane.
Shure:  说实话
Shure: To be honest, haha.
Tasha: 饿了什么时候吃饭
Tasha: Hungry, when do we eat?
Alice: 等一会吧
Jake: Will do.
Jake:几点了
Shure: What time is it?
Tasha: 噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun-dun-dun, buy a watch, buy a watch.
Tasha: 不知道他怎么放进去
Tasha: No idea how they put it in.
Alice: 这下面有碗啊
Alice: There's a bowl down here.
Tasha: 哦你说哦
Tasha: Oh, you mean oh.
Alice: 烤箱啊我以为你说要打这个哎
Alice: The oven, I thought you meant to beat this.
Alice: 要不然把这个打完
Alice: How about we beat this.
Alice: 你吃了
Alice: You eat it.
Tasha: 这个盘还没洗好
Tasha: This pan isn't clean yet.
Shure:  这个用微波炉
Shure: Use the microwave for this.
Alice: 不是这个
Shure: Not this one.
Alice:我给你洗个盘子
Lucia: These are useful.
Lucia: 箱子就扔掉去
Lucia: Throw the box away.
Tasha: 没关系
Lucia: Otherwise, it feels like it's taking up space.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 好了不用帮人家洗这么干净
Tasha: No need to clean it so thoroughly.
Tasha: 还要还的
Jake:好的
Jake: 比划一下
Jake: Wash it faster.
Jake: 我这是昨晚自带的
Jake: This is from last night.
Shure:  不是昨天的
Shure: Not from yesterday.
Alice:这 不是昨晚的吗
Shure: Not from last night?
Shure:  咱过日子就要有过日子的样子
Shure: We should live our lives like we mean it.
Jake:过日子的人是吧
Alice: 就是两分钟就行了
Alice: Just two minutes will be fine.
Jake: EGOlife都是过日子的人
Tasha: 你猜这个是用来干嘛的
Tasha: Guess what this is for?
Shure:  这个就行
Tasha: This, this  Shure: This will do.
Shure:  然后开始
Shure: And then start these.
Tasha: 他是用来插烤鸡的
Lucia: Yeah, it's for sticking the roast chicken.
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: Just like that.
Jake:妙啊
Shure: 过日子过日子
Shure: Living life, living life.
Tasha: 对啊在烤箱里转哦
Tasha: Yeah, it rotates in the oven.
Jake: 两边可以一起
Jake: He can do it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:真好学一学学一学
Alice:再来个盘子
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake:有人打我电话，原来是快递
Shure: Someone's calling me, turns out it's the delivery guy.
Jake:喂，你好
Shure: Hello, hi.
Jake: 稍等啊
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 哦这个需要热一下吗
Alice:对
Alice: 哎呀无所谓
Alice: Eh, doesn't matter.
Lucia: 对我把手洗一下刚才收拾一下
Lucia: Yeah, I'll wash my hands, just tidying up.
Lucia: 那啥
Lucia: Well...
Lucia: 这样如果需要弄弄盘子菜什么的
Lucia: This way, if we need to handle plates or dishes or something,
Lucia: 可以帮上忙
Lucia: it can be helpful.
Lucia: 要不然手太脏了
Lucia: Otherwise, my hands get too dirty.
Lucia: 这个要洗
Lucia: This needs to be washed.
Lucia: 这应该有纸我记得啊在这
Lucia: There should be some tissues, I remember. Ah, here they are.
Alice:桌上有
Shure: This is fucking awesome.
Jake: 来，大伙出去吃啊
Jake: Come on, everyone, let's go out to eat.
Lucia: 啊在外边那个桌子那里吗也可以
Lucia: Oh, at that table outside? Sure, that works.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 要摘眼镜吗还是吃完摘眼镜
Alice: 你什么时候想吃那个
Alice: When do you want to eat that?
Alice: 我可以随时给你做
Alice: I can make it for you anytime.
Tasha: 哈哈哈嗯看到了
Alice: Hahaha, yeah, I saw it.
Alice: 因为我已经有买了一部分了
Alice: Because I've already bought some.
Alice: 就很快那个东西
Alice: So it will be quick.
Tasha: 那可以今天晚上
Tasha: How about tonight?
Tasha: 当晚
Tasha: Tonight.
Tasha: 但是他没有主食
Alice: But it doesn't have a main dish. Tasha: Dessert.
Alice: 就是他是汤类的
Alice: It's a soup.
Tasha: 看大家今天晚上吃啥吧
Tasha: Let's see what everyone wants to eat tonight.
Alice: 可以
Alice: 可以配一个
Tasha: 嗯
Jake: We won't film it.
Alice: 你太可爱了
Alice: You're too cute. Shure: This table, honestly...
Alice: 太喜欢你了
Alice: I really like you, haha.
Alice: 你看那个花已经醒的很好了
Alice: Look, the flowers have woken up nicely.
Tasha: 嗯这样觉得醒的很快的
Tasha: Yeah, I feel like they woke up quickly.
Alice:展了
Alice:对嗯
Tasha: Yes, indeed.
Tasha: 然后叶子可以再去掉一些这样子
Tasha: Then we can remove some more leaves like this.
Alice:嗯
Tasha: 这样子它才不会影响
Lucia: How about we take one outside to use?
Alice: 醒花就要深水醒
Alice: 那个太浅了醒不了
Alice: That one is too shallow, it won't work.
Alice: 这个还行
Alice: This one is fine.
Lucia: 这抹布
Lucia: This rag
Lucia: 要不拿出去一个用算了然后就是到时候咱们洗碗就是拿一个新的
Lucia: How about we just use one outside for now, and then when we do the dishes, we use a new one.
Alice: 可以可以
Lucia: 我看看还有新的可以，我给它打湿一下外面的桌子有点脏
Lucia: Let me see, there's a new one. I'll wet it a bit, the table outside is a bit dirty.
Alice: 那个那个凳子也很脏
Alice: That chair is also really dirty.
Alice: 唉呀屁股已经上去了哈哈
Lucia: Feels like my butt is blocking it.
Lucia: 我还没坐
Tasha: I haven't sat yet.
Alice: 啊我早上嗯一摸一手土
Alice: In the morning, when I touched it, it was all dust.
Alice: 反正
Alice: Anyway, it's just dusty.
Lucia: 一直在室外吗？然后反正北京的风又挺大
Lucia: It's always outside, right? And the wind in Beijing is pretty strong.
Alice: 北京天干啊
Alice: 有那啥
Alice: There is something.
Alice: 昨天那个饼还有饼跟那个烤鸭
Alice: Yesterday there were pancakes and roast duck.
Alice: 你是不是喜欢吃这个
Alice: Do you like this?
Tasha: 哎还还挺喜欢的
Lucia: Oh yes, I quite like it.
Alice: 但是没有带甜面酱回来
Alice: But we didn't bring back sweet bean sauce.
Tasha: 啊是吗
Tasha: Ah, really?
Alice:啊没事这个没用
Alice: 我发现你你比较喜欢加那个烤鸭
Lucia: I noticed you like adding roast duck more.
Alice:我是不是很观察你
Lucia: Am I very observant of you?
Alice: 哈哈哈你好
Alice: Haha, you are funny.
Alice: 是不是很在意你
Alice: Does your partner care about you a lot?
Tasha: 是的我们CP粉
Tasha: 炒CP
Alice: 啊可以了
Alice: 来吧
Alice: 还有这个
Tasha: And this too.
Tasha: 我来端
Tasha: I'll carry it.
Alice: 走吧
Jake:时间哦
Jake:写一个1413吧
Lucia: sorry
Alice:没有
Alice: 哎呀倍儿脏
Alice: Ugh, it's so dirty.
Lucia:但是感觉一个抹布不够用 要是整个整个擦一下
Shure: 但是他真的很好用
Lucia: 因为一个抹布的话
Lucia: Because with just one rag...
Lucia: 感觉可能擦整个擦不太干净所以我本来说
Lucia: It might not be clean enough if we wipe everything, so I was saying...
Lucia: 光把边上大家用到的地方擦一下
Lucia: Just wipe the areas that everyone uses.
Lucia: 要不再再拿一个
Jake:再拿一个抹布
Tasha: 你不饿了吗
Katrina: Aren't you hungry?
Alice: 你吃吧
Alice: You go ahead and eat.
Tasha: 不敢
Tasha: What if I don't dare, right?
Tasha: 啊不好意思
Tasha: Ah, sorry.
Tasha: 没事我们现在是秋色吗
Tasha: Are we in autumn now?
Alice: 别做啊现在这个脏
Alice: Don't sit, it's dirty right now.
Tasha: 为什么6个人只点4杯饮料
Alice: 我不喝哦
Alice: I won't drink it.
Tasha: 你不喝嗯哎
Tasha: You won't drink it? Hmm.
Katrina: 我不能喝冰的
Alice: I can't drink cold stuff.
Tasha: 啊你也不喝
Tasha: Ah, you won't drink it either?
Katrina: 我不是这几天来大姨妈了喝不了所以我才睡这么死
Alice: I'm on my period these days, so I can't drink it, and that's why I slept so deeply.
Alice: 你是这几天
Tasha: Are you on these days?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈直接睡晕了
摆出来然后摆拍一张
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Katrina: 今天星期几啊
Alice: 2
Alice:今天是疯狂星期四的一半
Shure: 今天是Tuesday吗
Katrina: 对
Tasha: Tuesday
Katrina: 野餐呢
Shure: picnic day
Jake:疯狂星期二
Jake: So sneaky.
Katrina: 我手机哎
Shure: 干啥你手机放我手啊
Katrina: 我不知道啊哈哈哈哈
Lucia: I didn't know, haha.
Katrina: 我喝旺仔奶奶好嘞
Jake:我来我来搞一个
Lucia: 没事没事没事
Jake:还剩多少
Lucia: 呃差不多了
Lucia: 刚才那个就是硕把这边给擦了
Lucia: 有时候反应不过来他的全名
Katrina: 这是什么
Lucia: 这个名字还是蛮好记的
Katrina: 蛋挞披萨
Katrina: 肯德基出披萨了
Lucia: 这这凳子是不是也
Tasha: 为什么不点肯德基的蛋挞
Tasha: Why not order KFC egg tarts?
Lucia: 让我看看这凳子脏不脏
Lucia: Let me see if this chair is dirty.
Jake:怎么移不走啊
Jake:还想把这个送过来
Lucia: 好吧凳子也挺脏的
Jake:这个是闻所未闻的肯德基长成这样子
Jake:肯德基
Jake:我去
Jake:肯德基披萨
Jake: 这真的能笑话外国人
Jake:那他点的肯德基是什么东西我们的肯德基是什么东西
Katrina: 他们的肯德基跟我们不太一样是吧
Jake:他们肯德基只有汉堡
Jake:就是现在还是
Alice: 这是中式的有骨有骨鸭
Alice: This is Chinese-style bone-in duck.
Lucia: 对肯德基麦当劳新品好像国内外都不太一样吧
Lucia: Yeah, KFC and McDonald's new products seem different at home and abroad.
Alice: 有骨鸭米花
Alice: Bone-in duck popcorn.
Tasha: 呃口感也不一样
Tasha: Uh, the taste is different too.
Katrina:  夹了那种什么辣的，辣椒酱的那种鸡肉卷
Tasha: They have those spicy, chili sauce chicken wraps.
国内的肯德基麦当劳比国外卷多了
Alice: 中式鸭肉卷笑死  Katrina: 这是土豆泥吗
Katrina: 这是土豆泥吗
Alice: 哎是不是凳子不太够
Alice: Hey, are there not enough chairs?
Lucia: 但是那边那边的还没来得及没来得及擦啊
Lucia: But over there, those haven't been wiped yet.
Alice: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Alice: 这是没擦吧
Alice: This hasn't been wiped, right?
Jake:没擦擦一下
Alice: 抹布在哪
Alice: Where's the cloth?
Lucia: 这这4个都擦过了刚才
Lucia: These four were wiped just now.
Lucia: 那另外的还没来得及擦啊
Lucia: The others haven't been wiped yet.
Alice: 一遍根本就擦不干净
Alice: It just can't be wiped clean.
Jake:呃停吧
Jake:吃汉堡咱就不拍了
Jake:停
Jake:眼镜我放进去了在这晒坏了